and there's no telling
what spooky things may in fact be true i
don't know if you've been on the
receiving end of
you know recent rumors about uh our
conversation about ufos
very likely changing in the near term
right but like there was just a
washington post article and a new yorker
article and
you know i've received some private
outreach and perhaps you have i
know other people in our our orbit have
p people who are claiming that the
government has known
much more about ufos than they have led
on
until now and this conversation is
actually is about to become more
prominent
you know and it's it's not going to be
whatever you know whoever's left
standing when the music stops
it's not going to be a comfortable
position to be in as a
super rigorous scientific skeptic saying
there's no there who's been saying
there's no there there for the last 75
years
all right you know like like to the
short version is it
sounds like the office of naval
intelligence and the pentagon are very
likely
to say to congress at some point in the
not too distant future that
we have evidence that there is
technology flying around
here that seems like it can't possibly
possibly be of human origin right now i
don't know what i'm going to do with
that kind of disclosure right maybe it's
just
it's going to it's going to be nothing
no
follow-on conversation to really have
but that is such
a powerfully strange circumstance to be
in
right i mean it's just what are we going
to do with that if in fact that's what
happens
right if in fact the the
considered opinion despite the the
embarrassment it causes them
of the u.s government of all of our
intelligence
all the relevant intelligence services
is that
this isn't a hoax it's too there's too
much data to suggest that it's a hoax
we've got too much
radar imagery there's too much too much
satellite data whatever
data whatever data they actually have
there's too much of it
all we can say now is something's going
on
and there's no way it's the chinese or
the russians or
anyone else's technology that should
that should arrest our attention you
know collectively
to to a degree that nothing in our
lifetime has and now
one worries that we're so
jaded and confused and distracted that
it's gonna it'll get much less coverage
than
than you know obama's tan suit did
you know a bunch of years ago it's just
it's uh who knows how we'll respond to
that but
uh it's just to say that
our the need for us to tell ourselves
a an honest story about what's going on
and what's likely to happen next is
never going to go away
right and and it's important it's just
the the the
division between me and every person
who's defending traditional religion is
where where is it that where is it that
you want to lie to yourself
or lie to your kids like where is
honesty a liability
and i and for me it you know i i've yet
to find the place where
it is and it's so obviously
a strength in almost every other
circumstance
because it is the thing that allows you
to course correct
it is the thing that that allows you to
hope at least that your beliefs that
your stories
are in some kind of calibration with
what's actually
going on in the world yeah it is a
little bit sad to imagine that
if aliens on mass showed up to earth
they would be too preoccupied with
political bickering
or to like these like fake news and all
that kind of stuff
to notice yeah the very basic uh
evidence of reality
i i do have a glimmer of hope that
there seems to be more and more hunger
for authenticity
and i feel like that opens the door
for a hunger for what is
real like that people don't want story
they don't want like layers and layers
of of uh like fakeness
uh and i'm hoping that means
that will directly lead to a greater
hunger for reality and reason
and truth you know truth isn't dogmatism
like truth isn't uh authority i have a
phd and therefore
i'm right truth is almost
the like the the reality is there's so
many questions there's so many mysteries
there's so much uncertainty this is our
best
available like a best guess and we have
a lot of evidence that supports that
guest
but it could be so many other things and
like just even conveying that
i think there's a hunger for that in the
world to hear that from scientists
less dogmatism and more just like
this is this is what we know we're doing
our best given the uncertainty given
i mean this is true with the obviously
with the virology and all those kinds of
things
because everything is happening so fast
there's a lot of
and biology is super messy so it's very
hard to know stuff for sure
so just being open and real about that i
think i'm hoping will
change people's hunger and openness and
trust
of uh what's real yeah well so much of
this is probabilistic it's
even so much of what can seem dogmatic
scientifically is just
you just you're placing a bet on
whether it's worth reading that paper or
rethinking your presuppositions on that
point you know it's like
it's not it's not fundamental closure to
data it's just that
there's so much data on one side or so
or so much
so much would have to change in terms of
your understanding of
what you think you understand about the
nature of the world if this new fact
were so
that you can
pretty quickly say all right that's
probably right
like and it can sound like a fundamental
closure
to new conversations new evidence new
new data
new argument but it's really not it's
just it really is just triaging your
attention
it's just like like okay you're telling
me that uh
your best friend can actually read minds
okay well
that's interesting let me know when that
person has gone into a lab and actually
proven it right like i don't need i
like this this is not the place where i
need to spend the rest of my day
figuring out if your buddy can can read
my mind
right but there's a way to communicate
that
i think i think it does too often sound
like you're completely closed off to
ideas
as opposed to saying like this is you
know
as opposed to saying that there's
there's a lot of evidence and support of
this
but you're still open-minded to other
ideas like there's a way to communicate
that it's not necessarily even with
words
it's like it's even that joe rogan
energy of
it's entirely possible just it's that
energy of being open-minded and curious
like kids are
like this is our best understanding but
you still
are curious i'm not saying allocate
time to exploring all those things but
still leaving the door open
and there's a way to communicate that i
think that
that that people really hunger
for
you